i thought that the court system legal
system was going to be fighting for the
kids and i quickly found out that's not
the case
[Applause]
[Music]
what do i love most about being a daddy
do we have all day
because i can go on and on and on
i knew i always wanted to be a dad first
of all that was like a non-negotiable
for me and we grow up i got married and
when two guys get married it's kind of
hard to have a kid we had friends who
fostered and they had like the perfect
foster story and so we got our foster
license
you would think that kids that don't
know who you are coming into your house
they're coming and meeting you they're
going to be shy and they're going to be
you know withdrawn and they just have
gone through whatever traumatic thing
coming into foster care and it wasn't
like that they just hugged us and
immediately just
just held on like they had known us
forever and it was amazing
that was it it was it was over for us
then like this is our life
jeremy and arlem took in these kids they
made them part of their family but these
kids came to them with very difficult
histories
they had bruises and burns on them
what should matter in terms of how kids
are placed is that they are placed in a
stable loving home where they can move
toward permanency and we have laws in
this country about that in the 90s a
bipartisan group of lawmakers came
together
and passed the adoption and safe
families act and it said if you have
been in foster care for 15 of the last
22 months the state should be moving to
terminate parental rights
and we regularly flout this law for
years
children in foster care spend an average
of
more than two years in foster care and
in many cases they are spending three
four five years
so
put it together
okay
that's right
you say you can't but you just did
and gets ready
for
the mother wanted this child back or she
would say she did but she was not
willing to live with any of the
conditions that the court set
i thought that everybody
the court system legal system was going
to be fighting for the kids
and i quickly found out after the first
time we were in court that's not the
case
every appointment that they had every
visit that they had it was completely
based around the parent and
whether
they could make it whether they had a
ride rather they were feeling up to it
that day they gave her chances to go and
get drug tested she wouldn't show when
it came to actual visits she would go in
blocks where she would see them you know
maybe two weeks in a row and then we
wouldn't see her for two months and it
just went on this way every time we went
to court it was just excuse after excuse
chance after chance and there was never
a point where someone said enough is
enough like you're not doing anything to
actually
get your kids back the idea that judges
regularly dismiss or don't even listen
to people who have cared for vulnerable
children for a year two years three
years is not a recipe for success we
need to make foster parents aware that
they actually have a legal right to
speak up in most court hearings and that
the judge should be listening to what
they have to say
so the next court date they said you
know mom showed up for visits the last
three weeks
all of a sudden mom's attorney files to
change the case plan the case plan has
been severance for two and a half years
they file
based on like three weeks of her
interaction to change it to
reunification
and the judge agrees i mean i'm sitting
in the courtroom and my heart sinks
we had built this life and this family
and the system just decided to just
pluck him out of it and put him in a
situation that he should never have been
in
and we should have never been in that
position where they could do that
[Music]
eventually during some visits there were
some questions about mom's parenting and
then there was one instance where
finally someone outside the home called
in a complaint and that person found
something we don't know what it is we
still don't know what it is they never
said anything we found something they
removed antonio
so antonio came home there's so many
tears but the thing that really hurt the
most was antonio really didn't know who
we were for a minute and he was a little
different he was a little different then
he started talking about having to hide
from the bad guys
and it was just heartbreaking that he
had to hide from the bad guys and listen
to the gunshots he was just afraid of
everything he was afraid to be left
alone like if he didn't see jeremy or i
like visually in a room like he would go
looking for us i mean we couldn't be in
the bathroom for five minutes without
him like screaming out yelling out for
us he just wasn't the same kid
[Music]
[Music]
their story did end happily and they
were able to
bring him home
but i think it's also important to think
about the trauma that this child
experienced
to have the first years of your life be
in this constant back and forth and
never knowing where your real home is
and where your real family is and that
you're going to be kept safe
[Music]
i still love you
[Music]
you